the morning believe nation today this is
it don't give up on your girl I would
say to continue to work hard and don't
give up on your goals and I know for me
like I said I grew up watching my family
struggle and I grew up with a family
that was successful but not born
successful and I believe with hard work
and with a goal and and love and
positivity then eventually we're gonna
be fine so this is a really important
message and I think if there was ever a
group of people who needed encouragement
not to give up on their goals its
entrepreneurs because it's hard right in
the business right it's one of the
hardest things that you're ever gonna do
in your life is try to become an
entrepreneur and things won't work out
as you thought they would and things
will always take longer than you thought
they would and that business plan that
you made that you are trying to stick to
isn't working out like you thought it
was gonna work out and you know you may
be running out of money and you may be
thinking I have to go back and get a job
and you may be thinking that my dream is
not possible and I think that's what
every entrepreneur goes through at some
point in their life what's important to
realize is that if this is something
that's really important to you this is
really your dream this is really that
big goal that you want to accomplish you
have to find a way to keep going even if
that means going back and getting the
job you know you have to find a way to
keep going even if that's 30 minutes a
day on your business you have to spend
that time every single day growing your
business an important framework that I
use is trying to live with no regrets
and if you look back on your life when
you're 17 years old and look back to
this day and you're thinking about
quitting and giving up and giving up on
your dreams thinking it's not possible
will you regret that you regret having
to go back and get the job and throwing
it all away
or will you wish it you try a little bit
harder and you gave a little bit more
time and so if it's something that you
feel is real
important part of you something you feel
like you're gonna regret for the rest of
your life then you owe it to yourself to
keep going and never give up on your
goals
so my question the day for you today is
what is the big goal that you have that
you're never going to give up on leave
it in the comments below I'm curious to
find out thank you so much for watching
and continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of an espresso
let me finish recording mr. Wow what was
I saying
okay hi mister